Hellooo!
Hi! How's it goin'?
I finally got it! I got the 10-million subscriber plaque! WOOOOO
I think it's pretty much just because Felix made a big stink about his,
But I got it as collateral damage, which is just as good as anything about getting it out of pure merit.
But it's really cool.
And it's... REALLY heavy.
And this probably shouldn't have been the first thought when I got it,
But I... I imagined how easy it would be to beat someone to death with it,
Which probably reveals something very bad about my personality.
BUT I GOT IT!                              YEAH!
And it's so cool!
I know... I... I shouldn't say that cliché so much,
But it's really, really awesome.
And I only have you guys to thank for it, and I actually don't know what I'm gonna do with it.
Because I'm not one for awards, I'm not one for collectibles, I'm not one for uh... keepsakes and stuff like that.
But this is special!
Because it- it represents, like, how far... we have come as a community and it represents,
You know, how much WE have accomplished.
And, I think...
As testament to how much I appreciate this award,
I'm going to be walking around the entirety of VidCon
WITH this, IN my arms,
*Giggling* Much like when I got the Taco Trophy that was given to me by Ra-
I'm gonna go get it!
Hang on!
Much like this Taco Trophy that has been by my bedside since I got it!
Some of you noticed that in the background of my videos,
Uh, yeah, I keep it by my bed because I'm so proud of what I've done to win this Taco Trophy,
And this is just as cool!
Maybe even cooler, I don't know, they're kind of 50/50 on the coolness scale.
But, I'm gonna be carrying this around with me at VidCon, which is just in a few days.
Also JackSepticEye is currently in town,
And, uh, we're gonna be doing a lot of cool stuff.
Follow us on social media so you can see all the stupid pictures that we're gonna take!
And stuff.
So we're all gonna be at VidCon and we're gonna be having a great time. And I don't want you guys to worry,
Because this year there's going to be, uh, much higher security- while we're there
Obviously in relation to what we talked about on the last vlog.
But I don't want you guys to worry at all.
We're still gonna meet,
Everything's still gonna be fun,
Uh, we're gonna be there, like, we- Me, Jack, you know, all my friends...
We go there...
To meet you guys.
And we don't want anything to get in the way of that.
And things might be a little bit different this year,
But that doesn't mean that we're gonna meet any less of you guys.
I go there- not to network, not to socialize, not to hang out, not to go to parties,
I go there to meet you guys.
And I'm gonna be carrying this around with me!
I just won't be able to go on the public floor with it.
So, look for me!
If you find me, say hi!
But I don't know if I'll be able to go around and just walk around wherever I want.
But it's still gonna be a good time,
And then after that, uh, next month-
I am going to Comic-Con.
Which should be- if you met me last year at Comic-Con, you noticed that it was a little bit crazy.
There were a lot of people, and then Comic-Con got angry because we were blockin' up the hallways.
Actually, the Marvel booth got angry because we were blocking up THEIR-
Like their big whatever-the-heck they were advertising.
But it should be a lot better-organized this year, we're gonna be selling posters that I'll gladly sign for you guys.
And if you don't know, these are the poster covers!
They're there-ish and things!
And if you didn't know these are the cover art for the upcoming Markiplier comic,
Which is still available- I think?
I think if you order... in the next, like, week you can still get the July version.
But they're coming out like July, August, whatever the next month is.
Don't question my ability to count months. I know what months come after August- do- that- nyeh
So you can still get them in their exclusive foil-cover version of it,
And then after this initial run you'll be able to get it, uh, later but it just won't be the foil cover.
So if you want that, uh, check the link in the description below, you can still get it.
So,
*High-pitched screech*
So in other news, while Jack is in town we should be making a lot of collaborative videos.
And also we're gonna be working on the Ninja Sex Party shoot.
And ALSO, at the end of this week,
Uh, Night 4 of the Five Nights at Freddy's musical with Random Encounters will be coming out.
Uh, I'll let you guys know about that, but just keep an eye out. I think it's gonna be on their channel on Friday.
I'll put links in Facebook and Twitter and wherever I can to get to it.
But thank you guys so much for supporting that effort
and thank you guys so much for supporting us in making videos.
I think Jack might've gotten this also, so...
*Laughing* I don't know if he brought it with him to VidCon, but if he did,
I'm gonna talk him into both of us carrying this around SO proud.
And if he doesn't have it, then I'M gonna carry it around and GLOAT about how much better I am than him!
Because I also have a Taco Trophy.
So... thank you guys so much for watching. I can't wait to meet you guys at VidCon,
I can't wait to meet you guys at Comic-Con, it's gonna be a lot of fun,
And we're gonna do some cool stuff while we're there.
So thank you again everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see YOU...
In the next video!
BUH-BYE!!
*singing* I can't wave I- my hands are full.
*gasp*